all right so lima lima yum
ramovich yeah brahma [ __ ] you have a
company
called aura and what do you guys do
so we're all about data-driven healing
our goal is to
use technology to scale affordable high
quality treatment services
how did you start doing this what got
you into this in the first place
so my our father growing up was very
abusive to my sisters and i
and my mom left when
i was about five years old and my
sisters were around three years old
and i remembered everything absolutely
everything so
growing up there was nothing that my mom
could do to make me feel better
i was a miserable child and very angry
all the time
and dealing with all of that throughout
my life and learning how to cope
is what initially made me want to go
into mental health
so what what do you think causes these
problems why do you think this exists in
our society
yeah so it's not about a housing issue
it initially started with abolishing
slavery and trying to get cheap labor
and that's when we began to try to fill
our prison systems
and we closed mental health facilities
to open up
more prisons a lot of the funding cuts
ended up
you know being taken out of mental
health and so that's why you see
so many people on the streets with
mental health issues
another problem is that when you look at
the numbers
of people who are imprisoned roughly
about 60 percent of them
have are in there for substance use
related charges
and roughly about the same amount 60
percent
also have diagnosed mental health
conditions with about 20 percent
having severe illnesses like
schizophrenia
um so it's all about right now our
system is about punishment over
treatment
and really monetizing that labor and
they're taking all of the funding away
from mental health services
and putting it into other resources
which is completely damaging our society
and so if we put
more services more funding behind mental
health services
we wouldn't have such a horrific mental
health
and homeless situation happening in our
country
so what you're suggesting is the
appropriate response
is more treatment for the mental health
issues absolutely
it's all about treatment over punishment
and really learning how to help people
what got you into this field i mean your
your history with your family
sounds like yeah so um like i said i
initially didn't remember
my sisters didn't remember any of the
trauma but i had a
you know i i remembered everything and
um throughout my childhood and
throughout my teenage years
i just got mixed up with the wrong crowd
and
my sisters were the poster children for
the perfect child they were identical
twins they
were athletes they had straight a's they
had no recollection of the trauma and
then
um roughly within their mid-20s
they began to hear voices and
um they didn't know what was going on
but because of the mental health stigma
they didn't come to my mom or
my myself they kept it a secret but they
did
do the right thing and they sought
professional help and so the doctors of
course had
absolutely no tools to treat them
they're mental health therapists
so they go and they ask them how are you
feeling
and then they started prescribing them
cocktails of medications
and drugs um and so at that time my
sisters had a
very successful youtube channel their
career was on
the up and up and rising and
once they started to seek treatment is
when it all went downhill from there
so they began at the beginning they were
prescribed antipsychotics misdiagnosed
for about three years
they were told that they were
schizophrenic which is not the case
and it's the the way that we treat
mental health services right now is the
equivalent of me
i'm telling you mark my leg hurts i
think it's broken
and then you ask me well on a scale of
one to ten
how bad is the pain and i look at you
and i tell you
maybe it's a seven and so then you tell
me oh it's probably not broken it's
probably fractured take this medication
and um if it gets worse then come back
and we'll put a cast on it that's
basically what we do to your brain we're
playing russian roulette with your brain
every time we prescribe
you medications we're slightly changing
the chemicals in the brain
when we really don't know what the issue
is and so
after three and a half years my sisters
were finally properly
diagnosed with dissociative identity
disorder which is extremely dangerous to
treat within
psychotics because of that three-year
period
the antipsychotics were not working um
the doctors were giving them cocktails
of antipsychotics
benzosocolonapin and xanax and
eventually because the kolonopin
destroys the reward receptors
somebody prescribed them suboxone which
is a synthetic opioid
and they ended up developing a
full-blown opioid and benzo addiction
that's completely destroyed our family
so
but initially the cycle is that they go
to treatment for 30 days because that's
what insurance will cover
the first approximately 10 days is
horrible because you're just detoxing
your body um
after that when the drugs are completely
out of your system and they're trying to
treat you
with therapy for about two weeks your
brain
essentially medications are like putting
your brain in a wheelchair
so if i put you in a wheelchair for
three years
and then i ask you to stand up you're
not going to be able to walk
nonetheless be able to even stand on on
your legs
and so if you've been taking meds or
self-medicating or very dependent on
different types of medications and then
they're taken away from you when you've
detoxed
your brain doesn't know how to manually
produce
the chemicals on its own it's very
dependent and has been essentially
crippled by this medication
so during that detox period as soon as
your body is completely
cleansed of those chemicals it doesn't
know how to produce it on its own and
it's very much depleted
so you just feel awful all the time and
a lot of times
those people need to sit in that awful
feeling and it's too overwhelming for
them to do so
and so initially after detox
the following about two weeks is the
brain
learning how to function without that
medication so you are just
hating life therapy is not getting
through to you nothing's really making
sense
you just want to leave and then your
brain is now starting to produce its own
chemicals and function on its own
it's you're learning how to stand up
let's say right all over again that
physical therapy
starting to have an effect so the last
week of treatment the last
week of that 30 days you're starting to
benefit and you're starting to seem like
you're getting better
and then you're immediately released
because insurance won't cover
continued care the reason for that is
because it costs about forty five
thousand dollars per month
for somebody to get treatment in
resident in a residential facility
that doesn't include the initial
hospitalization the detox period
and all of the medications and
everything else that goes into that
and it's a it's very expensive but the
relapse rate is 90
so with a 10 success rate the
insurance companies are saying we are
not we're not going to fund
45 45 45 when you have such a high
relapse rate
the clinics it's a catch-22 because the
clinics are initially saying
well on
average most patients have been
self-medicating
um or initially addicted um or harming
themselves for 15 years
or more they've been they've been taking
these matters into their own hands
and you can't expect us to change
15 years of a behavior pattern in only
30 days
and then expect it to last and so with
my sister's case
they've been to over 60 treatment
centers
and the story is always the same it's 30
days of treatment
you know they leave there's no
door-to-door treat
there's no door-to-door care there's
such a high demand for these services
that there's not enough doctors to treat
the number of patients that needs needs
help especially since the opioid
epidemic
there's been a 600 percent increase in
the number of patients
trying to admit themselves into
treatment
so there's a nationwide shortage of beds
and doctors and staff and support and
help
and so they leave the 30-day treatment
they feel suddenly like they're on their
own
a lot of these people as you know have
this story that they tell themselves
that nobody cares about me i'm by myself
nobody
nobody wants to help me so when they're
starting to get better in a facility
and then they find themselves abandoned
again
then they just feel like i'm completely
alone with my
illness or my addiction and the only
thing that they know
because the thing that makes them feel
better is an instant immediate
satisfaction whether that be cutting
whether it be
high risk behaviors being promiscuous
compulsive caffeine consumption shopping
addiction like me
right so there's so many different ways
um and these are very common these are
what are
i call negative coping skills um so
they're very common
um but addiction is not just an
addiction to drugs or alcohol
it's initially the inability to say no
right
so it's um it's the it's the inability
to set those boundaries for yourself
and i notice that a lot of times you ask
i mean i think every time
you ask the people that you're
interviewing tell me about your
childhood
it really does start in childhood
because
you need a healthy balance so if if
someone comes from
a place where there's too many
boundaries right
where the parents are very very strict
with them and their
you know can be also abusive in in how
strict they are
that can be completely debilitating to a
child
growing into an adult and the same thing
can be with no fruit with too much
freedom
where parents just allow you to do
whatever you want um
children need healthy boundaries so that
they can
learn to say no and they can they can
understand their self-worth
and you have to find that balance but if
you have parents that are
too freeing and are too consumed with
what
they're personally involved in and they
don't pay attention to the kids
or if you have kids that are parents
that are too controlling
you have your boundaries completely
screwed up um and so that's that's where
it all starts with not having
proper boundaries in place um and
um and becoming addicted to your own
self-destruction
and a lot of times when we say treatment
people assume that going to therapy is
so mark tell me about how you're feeling
and then you just puke everything out on
me and then
you leave and you feel great after your
therapy session that's
really not how therapy works um
therapy starts when you step outside the
door right so
one of our therapists her name is alana
and she
she uses our technology she works with
veterans
so she always tells her veterans that
therapy is all theory and it starts the
work starts when you leave
the reason that she loves our technology
is because
she's able to track how the patients are
doing
um we use voice analysis we use
biofeedback
so you can actually see how a patient's
feeling i'm not just asking you
how bad is the pain right i'm actually
i give the doctors the tools to see so
if you tell me
that you know you're fine and i look and
i can see that you're not fine
addicts are master manipulators they
have it spot on on how to trick you and
on top of that my sisters are
the best actresses so it's hard enough
for me to read them
but being able to have tools that you
know when
when someone's been just so gone to
treatment it hasn't helped gone to
treatment it hasn't helped gone to
treatment it hasn't helped
they initially give up on treatment and
they feel like they know better and
especially when i go in
to see a doctor and they ask me how are
you feeling
and i tell them i'm fine and they're
like oh that's good
then i feel like i can't trust that
doctor because they can't see behind the
mask so they can't help me
so if it's so easy for me to fool you
then
you can't help me and so that that
initially discredits a lot of the
therapists or the therapy sessions
the ability to just be able to see how
the patient's feeling
we also use virtual reality so we can
put patients in triggering environments
and you know for example we put a
patient
in a bar where we put or for our
veterans we put them in a war zone
we've learned a lot about
their response to certain things
it just gives us a lot it's all about
having that fast
richness of data to really be able to
analyze the situation
and steer the the conversation in a path
that it wouldn't have gone otherwise
just because there there's so many walls
around these people
um that they're just not willing to let
someone in so you kind of have to find a
way to gain their trust
and show them that you actually can help
them and that you can see how they feel
and it's not all in their head because
especially with my sisters there's been
so many times where they've said
maybe d.i.d isn't real maybe nobody can
help me i'm just crazy
because up until now no one has been
able to help them
so so your company really gives the
therapist a window into what's really
going on
exactly with the patient exactly so
initially it's kind of like
not just their words absolutely so so
think of it
as like therapy and medication right um
you do need both
and but you but you need medication and
moderation right not the way that we
currently prescribe it where it leads to
you know addiction but independency
you need and you also need therapy so
right now our system relies purely on
medication
and very little on on therapy therapy is
just there so we say we do it
but it's medication to sedate everybody
and manage them
and the way that i the way that i
initially describe to patients or
colleagues is it's like a fire alarm
right so when i have a really awful
feeling
um that means that and it could even be
a midlife crisis whatever it is doesn't
even have to be an addiction right
um when i have a bad feeling that bad
feeling is actually really good it's
telling me that something's wrong and
you need to learn to sit in it and
analyze it
initially track and unpack that feeling
so
if there's a fire going off and you take
medication
it's initially like me getting up taking
the batteries out of the fire alarm
and then going back to sleep so i'm
going back to sleep in a burning
building
and you know the side effects are
suicide
self-harm just you know they're all
horrific right
um because if you depend on that long
enough the building's gonna burn down
and you have no warning signs
um therapy is about looking for where
the fire
is right and so um that's
that's what our goal is is to scale
treatment so that you can learn how to
sit in these bad feelings and that
you're
you're when you refer to that feeling
it's not
i feel awful because i hear that from my
sisters all the time i feel awful i feel
awful
it's about being aware of your feelings
so
is it sad is it fear is it anger what is
that feeling
and then let's analyze where it's coming
from and once you can identify
what triggered that feeling you can
identify how to initially respond to it
or you can identify um
you know how to avoid certain things
that end up leading to that feeling and
it's like a domino effect
but if you're constantly like i feel
awful this is a bad feeling let me take
the batteries out of the fire alarm
then you're constantly quieting that
feeling and you're not getting better
so if you're if a therapist is speaking
with a patient and
there may be some shame or anxiety or or
something going on
that they're masking or hiding the
therapist kind of has a window into it
absolutely so they can they can see
we use evidence-based scales so
depending on what the patient is
diagnosed with right now our biggest
focus is on depression
we are a very young company it's a
start-up and i started it on my own
how many years has aura been around it's
been a year it's been around for
a year but i've been doing the research
for about seven years
so we were it was registered last april
um we managed to raise a small seed
round
we have 19 clinics that are currently
signed up with us
we have about 600 clinics that want to
sign up with us but we just don't have a
big enough team to support them
and we we don't have the tools to scale
scale our technology right now so what
we're working on
is we're getting ready to open up our
series a with private investors next
month
um we've had some really good traction
and a lot of really great conversations
and there's it it's amazing to see how
many of these investors
have experienced mental illness and
loved ones
and they're very motivated with the same
reasons that i'm motivated by
so i couldn't imagine being in a better
industry because there's so much heart
in it it's not all about
how much money we can make of course
there are those people
but those are not the people we want to
work with it's about
the people that are thinking of how can
we
scale help for so many for everybody
and if you look at the different tiers
of treatment so
some of the patients that or some of the
people that you've interviewed
were talking about different treatment
centers that they went to
and they they were didn't have insurance
they had medicaid or medical and um
you know those treatment facilities they
they typically have
very small rooms um twin beds it kind of
looks like
a nice jail cell right there and they're
clients of mine so we we work with them
right
um so it's not talking bad about them
it's just giving you an image
of the different tiers of treatment um
they don't
they have a small outdoor space it's
very closed off
there's not really a lot of nature and
it's just a very
clinical hospital vibe um and then we
have
so those ones go for about like 18 000 a
month
to thirty five thousand a month um then
we have
luxury facilities that go from forty
five thousand
upwards to a hundred and thirty five
thousand a month
um their cash pay private facilities
and beautiful houses
on the water or just in a beautiful
neighborhood surrounded by
you know completely surrounded by nature
and
you don't feel like you're in a hospital
setting and those
the medicare medi-cal facilities will
usually have about like
100 200 patients not a large staff
it's mostly group therapy it's initially
a place to hold your family member for
30 days
until they relapse so it's a it's a bit
it's a glorified babysitter that's
holding them
right um the private pay facilities
they're
they have a smaller they take less
people which is why they charge a higher
price point
um and they also do more one-on-one
therapy
and and they have um
you know it's enjoyable to be there you
actually feel like people care about you
and it's beautiful i would check myself
into one of these facilities
just for the sake of a vacation like
it's it's just
very serene and tranquil and so with our
technology
with our virtual reality what we're
doing is we're taking the highest
quality of care
so the beaches and the beauty of nature
and the mindfulness practices that they
do
at these higher tier treatment centers
and we're providing a virtual
room where these patients can
in these other facilities can go and can
be on a beach
and can be in the mountain tops and can
do
mindfulness and positive practices
because around
like four o'clock the therapist will go
home and the patients are just left with
a tv room
and they're just being held there and
medicated
and so that's not very practical so with
our tools
we're constantly trying to replace
negative coping skills with positive
coping skills
so if you're someone that's very
impulsive that's used to
you know cutting yourself when you're
upset or throwing up
or overeating or taking your drug
of choice right those are all negative
coping skills and you
and you've gotten used to doing them
because the first time that you ever do
anything it's very nerve-wracking
um and then the second time you do it
it's a little familiar but it's still
you know it still makes you a little
nervous and then the third time fourth
time fifth time
eventually it becomes abnormal to not do
it so for example
if you're someone that goes to the gym
six days a week and
you miss a day of your workout you're
going to feel awful about yourself right
because you
are you have that um that daily routine
and you just broke it
um but if you're somebody that um and
i've been there right so i'll have like
that daily routine i'll be like i can't
believe i screwed it up
and then you know since my sister drama
i haven't been working out like i was
before
and all of a sudden
if i go to the gym once a week i'm so
proud of myself but the following day
that i don't go
it's not a big deal to me because i'm
used to not going
um so that becomes my behavior pattern
whatever
whatever i'm used to is is what i
constantly follow and what i reward or
you know put myself down for when it
comes to
self-harm like if someone for example
with an eating disorder
if they're used to if they at the
beginning
they throw up for the first time it's
kind of scary you know it's a scary
thing to
to even comprehend um it's very
uncomfortable i don't think anyone likes
the feeling of puking
right um so it's not a comfortable
feeling it's not a comfortable act and
it's a little it's a little scary
and so when they begin to do that on a
daily basis
it begins it becomes very uncomfortable
for them
not to throw up because now they've
retained that food and it's about
control
and you didn't control your in your food
intake
and um you didn't throw up and so that
becomes the norm so you
reprimand yourself for not doing it so
you broke that schedule or that comfort
level that you have created
and that became your way of coping with
stress and trauma
when i feel a certain way i respond this
way and when i don't do it
whether that be pills whether that be
you know food consumption and just
comfort eating right whatever it is that
you do
therapy is about breaking that pattern
but
if you don't get the therapy if you
don't get constant
therapy constant practice at breaking
that pattern
then initially you're never gonna you're
never gonna break it and you're always
going to go back to
what you're used to and so that's why
the the relapse rate is 90
um and people are not getting better and
unfortunately this isn't
um you know eating disorders have the
highest rate of mortality
because especially when you pair it with
bulimia
um like anorexia has the highest rate of
mortality and when you pair that with
bulimia
i'm your your heart has a higher rate of
just stopping like it just stops out of
you know it can't it can't continue to
support the body
opioids opioids now kill more more
americans than guns or breast cancer
and it's just because people have become
so dependent
on impulsively changing how they're
feeling and they're very addictive
the goal of what we do and what therapy
is supposed to do but they don't have
the tools to do it
and that's why we're building the tools
to do it is initially to
take those negative coping skills get
you to pause and not be so impulsive
and replace we're not just telling you
stop doing drugs
stop throwing up stop you know your
compulsive shopping habits mark right
we're not trying to do that we're trying
to we're trying to replace them because
you can't just stop and not know what to
do with yourself
you have to replace them with
mindfulness practices
not being impulsive taking a deep breath
one of the games that we have
is learning how to deal with anxiety and
stress and mood
so for example we've gamified the fight
or flight response
right so when i'm stressed out i'm like
very
tense and in um my shoulders are
up and i'm holding my breath and so i
can now see it in colors
and when i'm calm i'm taking a deep
breath and the colors change and
and it's and i have certain tasks so for
certain tasks i have to be super
stressed out for
and for other tasks i have to be super
calm so i learn how to control the fight
or flight response um and stress is
actually a really good thing and that's
a lot of people don't talk about it so
if people are interested i would highly
recommend
the book think fast and slow it talks
about the two
brain systems where
one is very impulsive and that can be
very good but also one is very
focused and it i can break it down i
don't know if it would be too long
but but yeah it's a very good book and
it really breaks down how you need
stress
you need stress to focus you need stress
to be motivated
if you know those people um i'm one of
them that
will usually have like two weeks to do
an
essay and then the night before the
essay is due
you end up cramming and you just write
the whole thing and you pull an all
all-nighter and then you submit it right
that's because those people like
when you have add or when you're just
very when you're always thinking fast
right um you can't sit there and focus
but all of a sudden when
stress kicks in my essay is due tomorrow
i can't fail this class
that stress actually gets you to sit
down and hyper focus
and finish it in one night so stress can
be very very very productive
but it's about learning how to channel
it right
has has aura had success stories with
some patients
yeah so we're actually piloting it right
now um we're working on getting the data
out there
uh due to the covid pandemic we've kind
of put our research
on hold um so we're still using it we're
still tracking patients
but we're not releasing that information
because
a lot of the uh we don't want our
numbers to be skewed
a lot of the treatment centers their
mental health facilities they can't
support
uh physical outbreak like a co the covid
pandemic inside the facility because
they don't have the staff
to care for the patient's physical
illness um so they've changed around
their protocols
we've been helping them see get
receive ppe supplies and um
and so just due to all of those shifts
um we've paused our our data collection
but
we have um we have seen
in little just small instances in
therapy sessions
where patients weren't even aware of
of their feelings because for example
somebody who's at a constant like for
let's use the scale 1 to 10 for easy
math right
um so if someone's constantly at a
stress level of
an 8 right and you ask them how they're
feeling
they're gonna think that they're fine
because they're used to feeling this way
all the time so right now i'm okay right
but the doctor can actually see that
they're not fine
and that they're actually at a an
elevated stress level that's being
maintained
just because they're constantly on edge
and so
we've had small little success stories
in the sense that
we've been able to identify these
factors
and we've also been able to monitor
people's craving levels and monitor
people's
stress and anxiety or even the ability
to remove
triggers right when for example if
you're in a treatment facility
and um i put you i put your
drug of choice in front of you that
would be extremely unethical it's not
allowed
right there's no drugs on the premises
if i can put that drug of choice in
front of you
just the visual of it it's not the same
as me showing you a photo
but being able to put you in a room
through our virtual reality technology
being able to put you in a room
where you um you know you essentially
are by yourself right so now i'm able to
test you because
it's the power of vr and it's also you
know the power of being silent and so
um all of a sudden you're at a bar by
yourself
for example one of our veterans right he
said his rock bottom
is being at home
by himself no one there just sitting on
the couch
with a bottle of jack daniels on the
table
right and so um so we were able to
put him in a living room environment by
himself
bottle on the table and measure
his ability to number one
use his coping skills because we can see
his craving levels we can see his
his stress levels immediately elevate
because he's by himself now we're
totally silent no one's saying anything
um and your your brain just
automatically goes into a mode where
you're you just feel like you know that
you're not in this environment
you know that your doctor is there with
you and that this is a safe place but it
doesn't feel like it anymore because you
don't see anyone there
um and so you're in this alternate
reality
we can measure the the trigger the
response the craving levels the stress
we stay silent and we see how long it
takes the patient
to use their coping skills their
grounding skills
all of the therapies that they've been
learning right because these are
initially exercises but if you don't
practice them
if i just do a couple push-ups i'm not
going to expect to be really strong
right i have to do it on a daily basis
and i have to practice when my trainer
is not there
so by being able to put the patient
in that environment stay silent and have
them do the therapies on their own
we can now you know monitor the patient
and when he's still
when he's let's say he's in level eight
and
he's how he gets himself down with his
grounding exercises to a level six
so now he's taking himself through
without the help of the doctor he's
practicing
it's no longer theory right it's no
longer
it starts outside the room now it
literally starts in the office with the
doctor
and so when the doctor realizes he's
having trouble getting from a six
lower but he's gotten himself from an
eight to a six
then the doctor will say okay remember
what we talked about take a deep breath
remember the story you told me about
your grandmother in the park think of
something positive
and so the doctor's able to get him down
to
a level four right with her help and
talking him through it
the ability to be able to show that data
to insurance
we're gathering all of that information
because our goal is for insurance to
cover
you know six months of treatment for
patients but
the only cost of mental health
absolutely so
so the cost of of real treatment would
be about
and this is very low right um
would be about 250 000 for a year for
somebody
um if you were going to constantly go
door-to-door so you have a scholarship
program
yes so i'm actually starting the
scholarship program
i just registered a non-profit called
the abramovich institute of behavior and
brain sciences
and so the reason for that is initially
because
i work in mental health my sisters have
insurance and our family is very
supportive and
working towards making sure that they're
always covered
the treatment centers that are my
clients are
beyond supportive of what i'm doing and
my situation are willing to discount the
bets
um for for my sisters to go
and um i know i know the industry inside
and out when it comes to insurance and
facilities and all of the politics
behind it
and i'm still struggling to find
treatment so
to me it's even unfathomable to think of
people that
are uninsured or don't don't have any
contacts in the mental health industry
where would you even begin right and so
um
the the reason for the mental health
scholarship the jibs
scholarship is initially it costs about
20 250 000 conservatively because we do
get a lot of discounted beds
through my clients and so it's about
offering the ability for somebody so
every 250
000 covers somebody for one year it's
about offering them the ability to not
just go to a medicaid medical facility
but they're able to attend an aura
facility so treatment centers that use
our technology
receive three months of residential care
receive the detox before that and then
after the three months of residential
care
they're put into an outpatient program
where they have
you know from 9 a.m to 5 p.m
they're they're going to therapy and
doing um treatment
and then they go home um so they have a
little bit more freedom
but the home is a sober living and it's
there's a lot of sketchy sober livings
out there but the ones that we work with
also have the aura technology and
so you can continue to practice what you
were learning in the treatment center so
those gamified therapies that are fun
but also retrain your brain
and they also have supervision at these
sober livings
activities they drive you to and from
the facilities
for your therapy sessions and then
initially after after another six months
so by month
nine you would begin job training and we
would cut down your
therapy sessions to the aura mobile app
so you do
a couple hours a week of telehealth and
we continue to track your progress
so voice analysis um
bio feedback and the evidence-based
practices through the aura guardian
system which is our mobile app
and so train you for for
job placement and ensure that you have
the ability to
move out of the sober living safely and
continue on that path but after a year
we've completely reprogrammed your
behavior patterns
so you're used to doing things
differently you have that support
and you're not automatically cut off
from 24
7 doctors surrounding you um you're
you're given that independence slowly
and it's not a
i'm not ready to leave so so that's what
what really drives me is treating mental
illness like physical illness
and ensuring that everybody has access
to the type of treatment
um that they need that it's not about
you know
i'm sorry you can't afford to get better
so
you belong on skid row it's a he um one
last thing because i don't want this to
get too long but
um in a three year period nevada
saw 80 million dollars in mental health
cuts
and there was 1500 cases
in that three-year period of one
hospital in nevada
dumping patients onto the street it's
called patient dumping it's very common
practice
a lot of the people from skid row end up
here because the ambulance drops them
off
when they can't pay for mental health
treatment they're not they don't have
coverage
and they can't afford to get better so
it's a huge issue in our country and
there's too much potential on the street
to let it just waste away
and then additionally we'll do a go you
want to do a gofundme campaign
for this scholarship right that would be
incredible
and then we'll yeah choose somebody to
be decided later
yeah so that we that you that you think
would be a good candidate for this
absolutely so i think it would be a
really amazing opportunity
to right now i'm raising the funds from
my friends and family
but anyone else that wants to
participate and
really add value to someone that they've
been seeing so it's not a housing
problem
it's not about getting these people an
apartment or getting them a home
trust me we've done it with my sisters
and it's only escalated the situation
and it's really about getting proper
mental health care treatment
and making sure that we take care of
this person for a year until they're
independent and that'll be somebody that
i've interviewed
exactly exactly and we can do updates
with that person
we can talk about the type of treatment
that they've been getting
um and you know use it as a way for
other people to see
the ideal of how our health care system
can actually work
yeah and they'll use or is technology
absolutely
they'll only be sent to um a private pay
facility
that uses aura technology so the highest
standard of care
with data-driven healing and the tools
for the therapist to see how the patient
is feeling
and to accurately use health detect
detection technology so that they don't
go misdiagnosed
and to really work one-on-one with that
person
until they're capable of being
independent and so you know one of the
things that i was just sharing with you
mark
is um the fact that we really have to
remember that these people
it's all about toxic shame so when you
and i
do something it's something that we did
when these people do something it's
something that they
are and so so they become very
shame-based
and the things that they continuously
fail at become more validation as to
how awful they are and how they don't
deserve anything so it's really about
showing compassion to someone
not sending them to a treatment center
where they're being sedated for 30 days
and then released onto the streets
it's about really providing a system of
treatment
and an actual recovery plan for them to
heal
excellent so i'll leave a link in the
description of this video and
we'll go from there thank you so much
lima thank you so much for telling us
about aura
thank you scholarship very exciting very
interesting
absolutely no i wish you the best of
luck with it
yeah and so uh sounds incredible well
i'd love to work with you to fill in
the first um scholarship person from
from one of the people that would be
very exciting that would be awesome we
can do an update for your guests
yeah of course yeah absolutely all right
all right cool thank you for having me
mark all right
thank you very much absolutely
sounds good